the government's seven days a week gp  pilot scheme was launched in april  covering seven and a half million people  at a cost of 50 million pounds the prime  minister said he would extend the  current trial to surgeries covering 10  million before the election and to the  rest of the country if the conservatives  are returned to power he said 100  million pounds would be allocated next  year another 300 million pounds to  complete the program but according to  the royal college of general  practitioners the scheme would need ten  thousand more gps and the same number of  practice nurses at a cost of one billion  pounds that leaves a shortfall of more  than half a billion pounds